we just had dinner this week I'm so
whole gang yeah the whole game everyone
was there everyone was there why is that
is that something that is unusual or
swimmer is in town and we all happen to
have a window of time so we look better
so did we
you really like that oh my god we
laughed so hard no one in that crew
annoyed you not one really lightning in
a bottle where'd you guys have dinner
where can you go that's Barneys at our
house anything go down but you need to
tell us anyone get naked
no nobody got naked it was very
civilized but we just laughed a lot do
you feel like you're on this set of
friends again in a way we all miss it
every day
really yeah oh I would think you don't
even look back on that oh yeah I would I
would be nothing without it would you do
it if they offered you a shitload of
money and I know to get you out of bed
we got to offer you a shitload of money
would you do a like a reunion show like
where everyone's now like older and we
find out what happened what if I if I
come up with some major dough for you
what would it take for me to get you
back in that role I don't think it's not
much
I don't think oh sure I honestly think
it would we would love it I really think
there is there is an idea that if if
there is a reboot of the show it will it
will be it what it won't be even close
to as good as well as what it was so why
do I would ruin it it would ruin it and
the legacy is everything right and the
money on friends was legendary because
you guys broke some boundaries there
well we stood as a solidary unit and and
asked for the exact same payment equal
pay and so that's right which is a big
deal
leading the charge ahead of our time
it's the it's very true it's really
quite remarkable